بلده عرور شمال رام الله مع مراسله
الجزيره جيفارا البديري في داخل منزل
اي والده
الشهيد صالح العاروري
جيفارا نعم حسن نحن بالفعل في داخل منزل
البيت العائله حيث تربى وترعرع الشيخ
الشهيد صالح الروري كما ذكرت والدته
المسنه قبل قليل بانها لم تراه منذ اكثر
من 20 عاما قضاها ما بين سجون الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي اكثر من 15 عاما ومن ثم تم
ابعاده ولم تتمكن من لقائه ولكن الشقيقه
ام قتيبه هي من كانت تتواصل معه اكثر وكان
هناك اتصال هاتفي هو الاخير بينهما اي ام
قتيبه الله يرحم
الشهيد كيف يعني اخر اتصال متى كان متى
شفتيه اخر مره يعني الوالده ما شافته من
20 سنه انت متى شفتيه سبحان الله السنه
الماضيه ربنا اكرمني بالحج وحجيت واج حج
هو والوفد اللي معه جميعهم وحجي مع بعض
الحمد لله رب العالمين يعني قعدنا يومين
ثلاث مع بعض والحمد لله ما شاء الله عن جد
يعني انهم جبال شامخه ما شاء الله كانهم
قران يمشي على الارض بتواضع ب يعني اقول
له يا اخوي خذوا احتياطاتكم يعني انت عارف
اليهود كيف يعني التهديدات والاغتيالات
وهيك يقول لي انا بعيش حياتي الطبيعيه
وبتوكل على الله وباخذ احتياطاتي طبعا بس
مش في نفس الوقت اني برضه بكمل حياتي
طبيعيه وكل يوم انا كل يوم كل يوم بتمنى
الشهاده وانا ساجد فش يوم بتمنا الشهاده
وطبعا ناس مجاهدين زي اخوي الشيخ صالح
والقيادات كلهم ربنا بيختم لهم في شهاده
باذن الله لانه هم طلبوها ونالها الحمد
لله واخر اتصال هاتفي بينك وبينه اخر
اتصال كان في 7
اكتوبر الفجر طلعت اشاعه انهم اغتالوا
الشيخ فرنيت عليه يوم رد علي الحمد لله
اطمنت يعني وقال لي لا تخافوا ما تخافو
يعني وصلت من الخبر قلت له اه وصلنا والله
بس هيك الحمد لله قال لي لا الحمد لله
وهينا بخير وهي ال دباباتنا دخلت على
المستوطنات والحمد لله رب العالمين ف طمنا
وقتها بس بعرف انهم راح يغتالوا يعني
اليهود فيش شي عليهم بعيد فيش يعني فش
جريمه بيعملوها فش اطفال ماخلصو منه اجنا
في بطون امهاتهم ما خلصن منهم يعني بدهم
يوفروا قائد ولا الحمد لله رب العالمين
الله يرحمه الحمد لله ودمه مش احسن من
دماء اهل غزه الحمد لله رب العالمين فداء
الاقصى وفداء فلسطين وكل طفل في فلسطين
قائد والنصر قريب باذن الله باذن الله
يعني من النصر الا صبر ساعه باذن الله
الله يجزيكم الخير يعطيكم العافيه